let's go to Thomas and Phoenix hey
Thomas welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
better than I deserve sir what's up I'm
married now have three children my wife
is back in Oklahoma and I just took a
job in Phoenix Arizona they just caught
my family
I think doctored all my resources
they're in Oklahoma and this isn't my
first time being having to search for
employment I was out of work for a few
months back in three years ago and my
wife has a master's degree and refuses
to work I'm sure was part-time
making $800 at the farm and so now we're
at a position where we're trying to make
a decision about the relocation here to
Arizona her trying to find a job
opportunity I'm expressing to her
you can't come to Arizona without a job
there's too much that you didn't work
during the time when I was out of work
and I just kind of wondering if that
would be the best advice even though it
does cause more debt I'm so confused why
would it cause more debt to have one
household instead of two households well
because she refuses to work and if she
moves to Arizona she would have to have
a job to help compensate for the
mortgage back in Oklahoma I feel we
could sell a home there well put the
house up for sale and sell it so that's
what we're trying to do a house up for
sale well that were actually working
with the realtor to get it get it going
how long have you been in the Arizona
I've been here for a month now okay so
why didn't you put the house up for I
want to take the job well because it
happened it was a three days I had to
make the decision well it was a month
ago and it was a month ago and she
actually well the day I left she said
that she had a job up in Oklahoma and as
she fought me on that federal bond about
staying in Oklahoma I don't I don't
think you have a financial problem money
give a marriage problem her I think the
two of you are not in agreement about
her career you think she should
working she doesn't have a desire to
work she doesn't think you should have
taken this in Arizona you took it anyway
you guys don't need to get on the same
dadgum page because there's not anything
that's gonna fix this until y'all get
your marriage on the right page and so
yeah she you need to sell the house and
whether she has I don't know why you say
she can't come to Arizona without a job
she lived in Oklahoma without a job well
because I can't afford to support the
family of my own you can't afford to
support the family on two locations yes
of living is much higher and I'm living
with my with my family for free here and
so the cost of living the sabri locate
them here would be higher than what do
you make in Arizona forty thousand a
year no and we have she had student
loans what do you do for a living
that fails okay all right I thought the
fluctuating fluctuating salary Hey okay
and I do not know what all is going on
but I do know that in the entire time
I've talked to you everything directed
towards your wife has been very acerbic
and very negative and you're pretty
disgusted with your wife I'm not sure
you're right but I do know you're
disgusted whether you don't even care if
she comes to Arizona that's what you're
telling me and so I think you have a
steep marriage problem and that's what
you need to work on and then that will
solve the career issues and the location
issues once you guys decide to get on
the same page and decide to put the
other person's desires ahead of your own
selfish crap and that's what both of you
are doing right now you're being selfish
children so I don't think your marriage
is gonna last if you don't get marriage
counseling this is the day for AMC show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind
you